I started making these maps to have a
beautiful representation of the places
I've traveled Yosemite
Zion Yellowstone Rocky Mountain National
Park and many more
[Music]
what makes Frank church wilderness
unique is just how large it is
you could fit all those national parks
within the boundaries of the finger Sh
my name is sheriff Prince I'm the
founder of mirror Way and a designer of
artistic Maps I started making these
maps to have a beautiful representation
of the places I've traveled my maps
aren't navigational maps they're meant
to be hung on your wall so that they can
inspire on a daily basis the Frank
church is part of the larger rocky
mountain range it has no entry point for
Humanity it has no roads the only way to
get in is by airplane or by foot
horseback or do you have to vote in
usually when I make a map it's a place
that I've already been
Coors Light has brought me to the Frank
church I'm getting to fly above the
wilderness and just see all the
beautiful mountains and vistas it puts
everything in perspective when you see
it from a distance
looking at the map then this is so cool
to see it stripped down and just seeing
the raw contour lines the topography
like that this is one of the few wild
places left in America and it needed to
be preserved oh god I love this place
[Music]
we're now officially in the wilderness
you can see how special this place is to
Mike you know it's just a special to
countless other people I mean on the map
you see via the contour lines so close
together you know that it is this deep I
incline but then when you see the real
life is just it's otherworldly no matter
what direction I look it's all
completely roadless wilderness the
geographic features are the highways
instead of highway you got a river
instead of street names you have
mountain peaks at valleys of creeks this
is how you get around
[Music]
[Music]
I want to see how accurate and detailed
this matha is I want to get a colors of
the place rivers the bends mountains the
ruggedness of the wilderness and that's
the essence of a map is that it inspires
exploration wonder
for this map we're going to donate a
portion of the sales of every map to the
Leave No Trace organization which
promotes the education and values of
being a responsible camper in nature we
can all make a difference to keep places
like this beautiful serene and clean for
future generations when I look at this
Frank church map I'll remember the river
I wrapped it down and the piece that I
saw on the airplane which was a magical
experience my hope is that you get a map
for an adventure that you've had and
that you get a map for an adventure that
you want to have
I'm very proud of what I create these
maps should last a lifetime
just like memories that were formed
there
you
Oh
[Music]